senti maneggiate fondo ho fatto tutte le
tipiche segui su instagram dietro dico
non inizia una relazione con un porco tu
non me la conta giusta
sei bello sei single hai un bel lavoro
qui gatta ci cova la mia vita sei uno
psicopatico 6 integrato 616 con scusa ma
quando devo venire teste dall'argine no
perché mi ricordo di quei cantine che è
morto quando avevo quattro anni era
intento di mio nonno
la riposta realizzata da questa cosa e
secondo me proprio a livello emozionale
di relazioni questa cosa che ovviamente
che ha rinviato perché adesso non riesco
più a fidarmi di nuovo se ti sembro
tutto cressi was a per i secondi non
ascendente capricorno che questo mese
c'è pure saturno conto in realtà sono
uscita potessero per fare ingelosire
niente possiamo fare una foto così la
posta me ne vado se team ha cambiato
argomento giulia giulia bianchi mi
sembra è su instagram perché le metti
sempre like non mi prendi aprono
storiche ma vorrei capire chi è la tua
ex io sono molto sensibile a questo tema
sono vegetariana da 2010 anni e lo
faccio per scelta e per principio
proprio perché gli animali non devono
essere toccati
sì per me un doppio cheeseburger con
abbondante baylon non le sono sempre
prese d'aria nacho oggi come fosse la
domenica per chi sta a dieta e se ha
tenuto e poi le strane però ho dato
un'occhiata i due social visto che c'è
una famiglia veramente gioco ma che
figari non madre sembra simpatica ma non
si credo ti chiami di stefano di cognome
e al fratello che si chiama claudio no
vabbè
no niente va al liceo
insomma un po delizia lì non ci sta ad
essa dire figli ma infelicemente un
fascino irresistibile ma totale
paternità ma perché devo presenta troppo
né amiche anni sa che lei piacciono i
brutti cioè non noi brutti però mi piace
ribelli appelli a lei piacciono i
simpatici simpatici con quelli che
l'inizio non può perde capelli un po
beatini ecco e poi soprattutto quelli
con un po di pancetta dai proprio esce
fuori
senti sono un po ipocondriaca quindi
semi portico esami del sangue tra domani
da me non avrà neanche un bacio sente
adesso perso la pazienza chi è che ti
sta martellando di chiamate pensi che
sia scema che non lo veda a me non piace
di kutcher con i tipi che sentano altre
ragazze ai tua madre ben peggio ancora
sarai un mammone uno di quelli che non
si schioda da casa che nei 50 anni
ammazza quanto manzi coeli dove c'è la
pancetta
certo con questa cena per i criteri in
palestra che lei almeno quello
ma lo sa che se spiccicato l'ex mio mode
farci vedere la foto bel ragazzo è
muscoloso possente io sono single
italiani ormai il tipo neri fatto e
decine sono un po uno mio cugino 1 e 1
con cui uscivo fino a ieri e ma poi
potete mi frega hanno interdetto l'uso
fidanzata si sono fidanzata ma il
ragazzo non è geloso e cioè io non
glielo dico grossi lo dicessimo sarebbe
geloso e quindi facciamo mercoledì e
venerdì sera che lui fa giocare a
calcetto
ci vediamo chi ci avrai capito che sono
una molto scheda quindi a casa due cioè
vera e volentieri le varie dare corrente
riina rinfrescatina però ti dico la
verità in mezzo alle gambe un cespuglio
che guarda domani mi sa che devo
chiamare il giardiniere perché si è
fatto tatuare chiara sulla spalla c'è
veramente
quando sei sfiga per si è tatuato nome
della tua hai tu mamma se ti va o che
sono tua foto dell'estate 2016 è e dov'è
c'eri tu con questo questo mino rosso
molto chiaramente e cappellino blu ma
insieme the c'erano altre due ragazze ma
tettona bionda e poi c'era una moretta
più bassa per un bel culo
ecco senti ma e rita caso in puglia ma
perché io sono state in puglia
quell'estate magari ci siamo incontrati
candy da quattro mesi esatti si sposa
mia sorella no e capisci che sembra
brutto arriva da sola quindi vorrei
arrivare accompagnata i miei sarebbero
veramente veramente contenti e tu vuoi
fare la parte del mio fidanzato e niente
io dove collinare un po cleptomane non
dopo nei negozietti rubavo mente con
borsa poi mi è passata grazie a dio e
crescendo ne son ripulita adesso ogni
tanto spazio ma occasionalmente devo
dire una roba proprio non frequente però
un backup ita di test ora sto benissimo
però melosa un periodo in cui sento
proprio queste esigenze di affetto di
coccole sotto il piumone che marcaccini
di un ragazzo mi va a fare la spesa che
mi prepara la cena che mi porta
dall'estetista e mica da driver mi porta
a fare shopping settima parliamo di cose
serie two aimi di progetti in futuro
matrimonio figli io guardan
entro due anni il massimo voglio fare il
matrimonio tre figli cane casa al mare
fumosa che in fondo mi sembravi diverso
cioè o più aitante un po più muscoloso
un po più affascinanti stesso sei
simpatico è bassino ma simpatico almeno
quello di mamma mia missione appena
arrivate guarda cioè non ti dica meno
c'è questo certo la terza guerra
mondiale da macelleria sangue teheran
che viene senti ma questa
marina of bici al maki e cioè perché la
segue a perché ti piace e guarda se ti
piace lei non ti possa piacere io perché
io soppiantare mora già a una simpatica
perché voi tipico nostra simpatica
guarda io me ne vado veramente continua
a seguire a marina ufficiale magari 10 c
pure e ciao io sono per la parità dei
sessi cioè che resta allora che l'uomo
deve sempre pagare
grazie e senti ma ho dimenticato il
portafogli guarda che testa che ciò se
per stavolta gentilmente valide e poi la
prossima faccio io
[Musica]